a partir de este martes ecuador impone
nuevas restricciones para combatir la
propagación de kobe 19 de establecer un
aforo del 50 por ciento en todas las
funciones en toda la función pública
hasta el 23 de enero el gobierno también
ha instado al sector privado a sumarse a
la medida y en lo posible implementar el
teletrabajo esto se da después de
registrarse un nuevo aumento de los
contagios tras las festividades
decembrinas las provincias más afectadas
son pichincha donde se encuentra quito
también manabí y pastaza y guayas cuya
capital es guayaquil reportó un alza
acelerada con más de 1.700 casos nuevos
en la última semana de 2021 lo que
también tenemos ahora en la mira parte
de la enferma ahora tiene una
vinculación con reuniones sociales y
reuniones familiares
con reuniones de trabajo ambiente
laboral y playas el aumento también
coincide con la llegada de la variante
omicron pero en su último reporte las
autoridades sanitarias dijeron haber
hallado más de 3000 casos de mutaciones
entre los que se encuentran la misma
omicron delta mu y alfa probablemente
tenemos muchísimos más casos del nivel
comunitario
pero también tenemos que tener presente
que las delta sigue siendo la variante
predominante prevalente en el país y
justamente la variante delta es la que
casos más complicados produce y también
más mortalidad ecuador es uno de los
países más adelantados en vacunación el
70% de sus habitantes ha recibido la
pauta completa aún así hace una semana
se convirtió en la primera nación de
américa latina' en imponer la
inoculación obligatoria ante este
aumento de casos que se prevé se
extienda hasta mediados de enero